il est évident que toutes les raisons
que je vous ai cité que l'or culinaire
est un patrimoine
[Applaudissements]
la culinaire est-il un patrimoine c'est
l'un des thèmes proposés aux élèves
participants au concours d'éloquence
organisé par le département des Yvelines
avec parfois un peu de stress mais
beaucoup de courage des élèves de 3e
sont montés sur scène devant 14 classes
à l'espace Coluche à plaisir ce mardi 18
avril moi j'avais l'impression de me
sentir au César c'est vraiment une vraie
expérience quoi c'est c'est vraiment
genre plein de bonheur et plein de ouais
de joie sur scène et comme la prise de
parole ne s'improvise pas sur plusieurs
mois les élèves ont été coachés à
plusieurs reprises par impro-actif cette
association basée à Versailles délivre
des formations sur l'improvisation
théâtrale et sur la prise de parole en
public il y a toute une méthode pour
réussir une prise de parole c'est pas
acquis c'est pas comme ça ça tombe pas
du ciel et donc ça manque encore dans
l'école française ce finalement cet
apprentissage de la méthodologie s'agit
d'un oral réussi c'est une super
aventure bien bien coacher par par les
comédiens d'impro actif et puis les
enseignants j'étais loin d'être seul on
était toute une équipe à donner des
arguments aux élèves pour qu'après ils
arrivent à monter leur leur intervention
décollégiens reconnaissants et ravis
d'avoir pris la parole devant une salle
comble de 400 élèves je suis super
contente d'être là et d'avoir gagné mais
grâce à l'aide collectif parce que
franchement 100 lettres de la classe ni
professeur je pense que j'aurais jamais
gagné Gabriel moque a remporté le
trophée du meilleur éloquent en duel et
trois autres trophées ont été remis le
trophée du meilleur éloquent en
argumentaire pour soumaya ou Bella le
coup de cœur du département pour Marie
Hans et enfin le trophée de la classe
lauréate a été remis au collège Les
Trois Moulins